Countless governments and companies have taken a stab at building a city of the future.
There's Songdo in South Korea,...
...the Alphabet-funded Quayside Project in Toronto,...
...which was abandoned in May of last year,...
...and both Singapore and Barcelona have tried to modernize with smart sensors.
In January of 2021,...
...Saudi Arabia announced plans for its own futuristic city called The Line.
Instead of communities sprawling outward from a central location,...
...they would be built vertically and arranged well in a line, hence the name.
Even though the vision for the city stretches 170 kilometers,...
...it would do away with cars entirely, and instead be connected by high-speed rail...
...that would travel the entire length in just 20 minutes.
And each individual community would be largely self-contained...
...so that almost anything you could need, be it a school, a doctor, or a quick meal,...
...would be only a five-minute walk away.
The government says The Line will run on 100% clean energy...
...and make extensive use of sensors and AI to manage the city's services.
And all of this is supposed to be nestled in the pristine natural landscape...
...of the Tabuk Province with minimal impact on the environment.
Now, the Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman...
...has revealed grandiose renders of what the city will look like...
...to match the grandiose plans.
The Line is envisioned as a giant glass and mirrored wall,...
...170 kilometers long, 200 meters wide and 500 meters tall.
That's taller than the Empire State Building.
It would have greenery stretching along the top...
...an open-air ventilation system to help maintain an ideal climate year-round...
...and it would house up to 9 million people.